[موسيقى]
سيسعى المنتخب الجزائري الى تحقيق فوزه
الاول في بطوله امم افريقيا الجاريه بكوت
ديفوار عندما يواجه مساء اليوم بوركينا
فاسو ضمن الجوله الثانيه في المجموعه
الرابعه المنتخب الجزائري كان قد فرط في
فوز بدا في متناوله امام انجولا في الجوله
الافتتاحيه يكتفي بالتعادل بهدف لمثله
يشار الى ان اخر مباراتين بين المنتخب
كانت في تصفيه كاس العالم فيفا قطر
2022 وانتهت بالتعادل في كلتيهما بحسب
الاصداء القادمه من كوت ديفوار فان اشبال
المدرب جمال بلماضي عازمون على تحقيق
الانتصار لاسعاد
جماهيرهم رياض
محرز منذ الزمان مش مش اليوم
في
19 انتقادات كانوا
موجودين حتى اليوم انا من شغل بالصحفيين
ومحللين
مش شغل في الميدان مع اللاعبي
وريض محرز هو ابطل
اوروبا ما عنده ولا ولا
مشاكل مع هذوك الانتقادات في المباراه
الثانيه وضمن نفس المجموعه سيحاول المنتخب
الموريتاني استدج كما فاته في المباراه
الافتتاحيه والتي خسرها في الوقت بدل
الضائع امام بوركينا فاسو وسيحاول تحقيق
الفوز امام انجولا للحفاظ على اماله في
بلوغ الدور الثاني لامم افريقيا في ثالث
مشاركه له في النهائيات خاصه وان لديه
مجموعه قويه من اللاعبين بقياده المدرب
امير
عبده فخورون جدا بما فعله الفريق لعبنا ضد
منتخب قوي على المستوى الافريقي وقدمنا
مباراه متكافئه واجهنا بعض الصعوبات في
بعض المراحل لا يوجد فريق صغير في افريقيا
وسنبذل قسار جهدنا ليفخر بنا
[موسيقى]
مشجعو